irenne Chagot propose voyage sans
[Musique]
passeport la Norvège terre de
légende la musique et l'art populaire
ont préservé des centaines de comptes
l'un de ceuxci celui que nous allons
voir raconte l'histoire du Petit fric
qui a gagné trois liards et les donne
généreusement à des mendians qu'il
rencontre sur son chemin et le dernier
mendiant se transforme en magicien il
récompense le petit fric en lui offrant
un violon magique qui a le pouvoir de
faire danser tout le monde le jeune
homme la sur le bailli et sa suite qui
s'avance sur le chemin le bailli est
offensé dans sa dignité et plus tard il
fait arrêter le garçon qui danse avec
ses amis dans une auberge au rythme du
violon enchanté le bailler va faire
pendre le petit fric mais celui-ci
demande à emporter son violon à la
potence magnanim le bailli lui accorde
cette faveur fric se met à jouer et tout
le monde se met à danser alors il
profite du tourbillon général pour
s'enfuir regardons les danseurs de
Norvège qui font revivre la légende du
violon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
magique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
IR Chag vous a proposé voyage sans sport
cette émission a été réalisée avec le
concours de l'ambassade de Norvège et
celui de Sange péter montage Pierre
Michel Ray script lu Andr son Gérard ben
Meyer